hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play pizza delivery
now I saw yamimash posted a video about
this game and it said scariest game that
I played in a long time and I went
really really really is it is it really
I don't know how pizza delivery game
could be the scariest game that he's
played a long time but I didn't confirm
with him so I will have to play for
myself and if not scary I will have a
choice word with yamimash but for now I
am shameless for stealing his idea
haha this doesn't look like this doesn't
look like or game at all it's late
you've reached the last delivery of your
house ok so anyway oh well I mean oh
hello hey Lucas my little o moped with
some comic sans wording on the side
always good was my piece I got a little
pizza box here but was this a gather
round the good stuff oh it's Pizza Hut
not sponsored by Pizza Hut in any way
but you know it's odd because this looks
like it has a lot more work than most
Unity engine games that I've ever played
so who knows this could be the scariest
game that I've ever encountered in my
entire life oh oh boy hello hello pizza
delivery I've got some big sausage for
you here hello I don't even know if it's
a lady hit rise up guy hello Wow ok
copyrighted music aside wait oh my pizza
hi bizarre
well I mean copyright music also I
shouldn't sneak it hello hello oh oh
whoa what the hell blood from the
ceiling oh my gosh it's so scary uh did
the lady shoot her
oh I took a candle just wanted to grab
this I guess it's my only light sir so I
better well um uh telephone alright
let's just go upstairs
I'm kind of curious like what's gonna
jump out at me cuz it seems this seems
like one of those jump scare games with
a lot of with a lot of just random
noises loud noises so I'm looking for
that oh hi hey lady
oh hello Harley I gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here
whoa No what is going on she's shooting
gouts of blood while she's hanging she's
floating actually moving very so oh
hello baby uh uh if you weren't floating
upside down on the ceiling and probably
dead I've usual you would be so fine but
not right now
ah I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here open
it no open what I miss Terri hmm how
strange
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Oh picture huh this
is a there's a comedy game isn't it what
hello
ok they're coming from upstairs
oh ok my baby's calling to me I gotta I
gotta go see what she wants
hmm hello ha ha
Hello Baby how you doing you seem to be
drifting lists list lifts to leap off to
the right there left left right phone
what the ah my baby she fell down mmm
hey no uh help me what hello who is this
what are you talking about I'm trapped
in oh I'm on the phone oh it sure was
going on as I was talking to the dead
body over there Annie how did I know
your name Hanny okay calm down are you
in the house I'm coming is Annie there
oh I can't talk about that right now
she's uh indisposed you got some
explaining to do okay then so is he
outside or something this is probably
probably the boyfriend of Annie uh sorry
bro I don't think he's due she's doing
too well I'm a delivery boy where's my
saw I'll show you the pizza the pizzas
right here man it wouldn't get here
without me yeah she's dead look not
anymore it's not it's not floating at
all it's kind of fell down this open
this door I wish I could it's kind of
locked you're in a lot listen to me you
poop I want to get the [ __ ] out of here
and I don't know what's going on
there will be a key upstairs on the
shelf go get it okey-dokey whatever you
say sir who's gonna be something waiting
for me upstairs in there there's gonna
be some waiting for me other I know
there's a jump-scare somewhere in this
game I know I know when my baby go Annie
Annie are you okay are you okay are you
okay Annie I guess that's the reason why
that song is playing in the beginning
Annie are you okay there's no key
there's no key what's going in hey sir
are you dead and floating down here
hello sir hey there's no key here but
you're not here are you Wow my pizza who
did this
wait all the pieces here one two three
eight okay all the pieces are accounted
for but Senor douchenozzle is missing
that sounds like a gunshot but I guess
I'm gonna find him upstairs floating
correct correct or is it gonna be Annie
again oh hi
daddy bear dear dear are you gonna keep
doing that hey buddy
Oh your uh man you don't look so good
there are you sure you're okay hello
what's your name
Annie are you okay are you okay are you
okay Annie all right then there's
nothing down there there's nothing over
here there's nothing over here oh are
you okay Annie
oh this is just complete silliness at
this point whose pizza it must be
pointing towards something what's it
pointing towards the fire Oh phone call
pizza what was behind me followed pieces
oh look it's my moped I'm not gonna
follow your pieces I'm not gonna listen
to a word you saw I can't go this way
what what is this let's just complete
ridiculousness y'all be match I'm gonna
have a word with you I need to have a
word with you young man you meet me
outside the schoolyard at noon be there
or be square coz it's game is ridiculous
this game is ridiculous hilarious but
ridiculous I've got to have a few choice
words to say with mr. mash
okay so what do we got here at the end
of the trail the trail of Tsar is the
Tsar pointing toward something oh hello
hi oh look it's Annie and her boyfriend
together at last all burning at last
ah what are you who are you always
behind me the future ah Josh yeah my
brain uh ah
why why why any of that why any he I
didn't make any sense at all the man
maybe there was a deeper meaning in that
deep-dish pizza oh man maybe the sausage
sausage was just a mystery to us all
oh I can't understand their attempted
hoods of all the pizza the cheese is
admit I know okay that was obviously I
hope that wasn't supposed to be taken
seriously because there's no way that I
could have I could in no way could I
have taken that whole thing seriously
maybe the way it made me laugh so there
you have it thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
Oh
by
okay Mike
Oh
you